-The Olympics start next week.
Athletes are coming in from
all over the world to compete,
and a lot of them
will be meeting each other
for the first time.
But sometimes
when you meet new people,
it can be hard to break the ice,
which is why a lot of athletes
come prepared
with their very own
getting-to-know-you
icebreakers.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Icebreakers."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Icebreakers ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Icebreakers.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so first up, we have
a snowboarder, Dusty Henricksen.
Yep, his icebreaker is...
-Aww.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You know,
these are icebreakers.
Next up, we have skier
Luke Jager.
His icebreaker is...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Just to break the ice.
-Yeah.
-Noice.
Next up is cross country skier
Jessie Diggins.
Her icebreaker is...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-♪ Breaking the ice ♪
[ Laughter ]
-After that, there's
figure skater Nathan Chen.
-Oh.
-His icebreaker is...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-♪ Come with me ♪
-Next, we have ice dancers
Kaitlin Hawayek
and Jean-Luc Baker.
Their icebreaker is...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next is snowboarder Red Gerard.
His icebreaker is...
[ Laughter and applause ]
After that,
it's curler John Shuster.
Yeah!
We love this dude.
His icebreaker is...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He's just breaking the ice,
literally.
-These are just icebreakers.
-Yeah.
And, finally, here's curler
Matt Hamilton.
His icebreaker is...
That's all the time we have for
"Tonight Show Icebreakers."